today's high speed trains will have you
cruising along at 350 km/h the ticket is
about the same as a flight and the
door-to-door time on some of the world's
most popular routes is the same or less
than getting a plane but decades ago
rail travel was in decline it faced
fierce competition from the air and auto
industries then came Japan's bullet
train by the late 1950s Japan's economic
miracle had transformed the war ravaged
nation its economy was growing quickly
the area between Tokyo and Osaka was
booming with industry people were
flocking to the capital for work but the
rail line connecting the two major
cities couldn't take the stress in 1958
a government panel was set up to tackle
the problem and several potential
solutions arose among them building the
world's first high-speed rail line many
were skeptical but two men were true
believers Shinji Sogo was the then
president of the state-run Japanese
National Railway the other so gos
colleague veteran engineer Hideo Shima
up against bureaucratic obstacles and
fierce opposition the two drove the
project forward in 1959 the Tokaido
Shinkansen line started construction on
the so goes leadership Shima was
appointed the project chief engineer his
team designed the sleek and
revolutionary cone-shaped front from
which the bullet train got its name
rather than being pulled by an engine in
front each carriage of the bullet train
was driven by an individual electric
motor which has proven to be safer
faster and more efficient apart from the
train itself the team also built wider
tracks which were more costly but
allowed for greater stability and higher
speeds 3,000 bridges and 67 tunnels were
built on the 515 kilometre line to allow
a clear and largely curved Ellis path
older trains were banned from the new
line equipped with advanced technologies
the new trains were able to travel as
fast as 210 kilometers per hour a
breakthrough in the passenger rail
industry and the world's fastest at the
time the journey time between Tokyo and
Osaka was cut from over six hours to
four on October 1st 1964
the new line opened just in time for the
Tokyo Olympic Games do not feed Becky go
then good evening one date the Hudson
you're good at that Tokyo at yasutani
savetti de cartier chemo but neither
Sogo nor Shima were invited for the
inauguration
they both resigned in 1963 because the
project's budget came in at double what
was promised 400 billion yen the
equivalent of 3.6 billion u.s. dollars
today but despite their premature
departure the Tokaido Shinkansen line
was an immediate success and quickly
turned a profit it transformed the
nation allowing more people to work in
metropolitan areas and became a symbol
of Japan's post-war re-emergence as an
economic and tech power now over 300
trains operate on the line every day and
the trip between Tokyo and Osaka has
shortened to two and a half hours the
number of passengers has also soared
reaching 165 million in 2016 after the
success of the Tokaido Shinkansen line
Japan has continued expanding its
high-speed rail network and plans to
build more following Japan's lead
countries like France Germany and China
have also developed high-speed railways
by the end of 2018 the total length of
high-speed rail network in the world
will be over 46,000 kilometers and over
half of it is in China
you